[Music]
first off have you guys even had a
chance to dance together yet wait we did
a couple little yeah little robot I
taught him a couple of us but we'll see
what did you think when you heard that
matches your partner what did you think
I was so excited I don't I don't know I
walked in and I was like I it was just
like looks a little girl wet to reshoot
it you know the I did trophy going to
the door so I was like well can I do
that again please they're like oh yeah
sure there's a bunch of dancers that are
actually celebrities this year so a lot
of people are like you guys have an
unfair advantage I mean do you think you
have an unfair advantage or I don't
think so at all I think the competition
is completely fair there's so many like
there's a gold medal gymnast like come
on yeah
I mean listen we will do our best what
will little swing as hard as we can and
see what happens I think everybody's
gonna do that too and that's looking
like for you I mean against your fiance
I mean are you do you guys bring the
work at home or you leave it on the
floor I got a mental at home it has two
vowels mirabal's yes to Peter's mirror
balls it's even like a little mirror
ball for the baby and my lonesome mirror
ball is standing by itself and it's
feeling insecure and needs a p2 cards
company for sure I just need to get
balls evened out and this is the
opportunity would you I'm not making it
stop look at that way
no pressure Heather Jesus I know I love
Russia Oh
I'm gonna hurt we gotta go now